قال رئيس منظمة الصحة العالمية إن
مجموعته تحققت من
250 هجومًا على مراكز طبية في غزة
والضفة الغربية و25 هجومًا من هذا القبيل في
إسرائيل. إيرين هوس مارتن هي
منسقة مشروع منظمة فرونتير الطبية
المعروفة أيضًا باسم أطباء بلا حدود، وهي
تنضم إلي الآن من  جانين في
الضفة الغربية المحتلة وأشكرك على ذلك. بيان منظمة أطباء بلا حدود
هذا الأسبوع في الضفة الغربية
حول جانين يقول أنه كان هناك
تصاعد في أعمال العنف مع تفجيرات واسعة النطاق
وإطلاق نار، أنت هناك في
جانين، ما هي أنواع الحوادث التي تعرضت لها أنت
وموظفيك  لقد كنت
أشهد أه مرحبًا صباح الخير أه كما
قلت أن هناك تصعيدًا
للعنف أه رأيناه طوال هذا
العام أه شهرًا بعد شهر
كان ذلك التصعيد حقًا كان العنف
يتزايد بالفعل أه ولكن بعد ذلك في
الأيام الأخيرة أستطيع أن أرى  أنه لم
تعد هناك مساءلة، لذلك كنا في
المستشفى، لقد أصيبنا بالرصاص في
المستشفى ذات مرة أه كان الأمر بجواري أم
أنا أم نعم حاولت استنكار ما
كان يحدث وأم كان الأمر كما لو أن لا أحد
يستمع إلينا  لقد كنا نساعد الهلال
الأحمر لجمهورية الصين الشعبية
أه مسعفي الهلال الأحمر من
سيارة إسعاف كنا نرافقهم
في المستشفى لأنهم كانوا
متوترين عندما كانوا يحاولون مساعدة
المرضى حتى نتمكن من رؤية أم نعم مثل
العنف بالطبع كان موجودًا قبل الثامن من
أكتوبر و و ولهذا
السبب كنا هنا لأن
المستشفيات لم تكن مستعدة للتعامل مع
هذه الإصابات الجماعية ولكن الآن ما
نراه هو أنه لم تعد هناك محاسبة
بعد الآن أه القوات الإسرائيلية
تأتي كل ليلة تدخل المدينة
وتدمر  الشوارع الجولة
حول الإقامات التي يقومون فيها
بإجلاء الأشخاص الذين يحاولون البحث مثل
أه أشخاص مشبوهين ومرات عديدة أه نعم
يقتلون عددًا كبيرًا من
الأشخاص مثل أه آخر مرة كانت 14 نعم
نعم لقد رأيت مقاطع فيديو لإسرائيليين
جرافات جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي تمزق الشوارع وما إلى ذلك
في الضفة الغربية بشكل عام وليس فقط
جانين كما أشرت إلى أن هناك
غارات متزايدة لجيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
وهجمات المستوطنين على المدنيين الفلسطينيين،
حصلت على عدد متزايد من القتلى وغضب متزايد
كيف تصف
الوضع العام في  الضفة الغربية
للفلسطينيين أوه نعم أه هذا ما كنت
أقوله هناك أشياء كثيرة
تحدث في نفس الوقت لذلك هناك
الكثير من العنف أه مع المستوطنين أه
لقد كانوا بالفعل مثل أه 1200
شخص في هذا المكان بسبب
المستوطنين يهاجمون أه من
المستوطنين أو حتى كأنهم
يهدمون المنازل
القوات الإسرائيلية ثم لدينا أه أيضا
القوات القوات القادمة إلى المدن
واحتجاز الناس 2500 شخص
معتقلين حتى الآن أه لدينا
أيضًا مثل دخول القوات الإسرائيلية
و أه وقتل الناس،
كذلك العنف الذي كان موجودًا
من قبل ولكن أه نعم المستوى
أه رائع إنه رعب هم